Một sau tháng 15 năm, hành hình khu chăm 1 năm, bình Việt đã qua bà dự đã tiếp nhận triệu hợp 5 miệng nơi nơi đe,
8 mi hai tuổi, 1 tài xả lông 2, thị phu xí mình, nhập viện trong tình trạng tên an rất thông nghiêm trọng.
Sau khi được các bác sĩ tham phám, hồ dình truyên khua, tình trạng được rất định tổn thương nó không thể hủy phục.
Chứ thực tế đầu lòng nó, các bác sĩ đã cho đổi và thương vấn vời ra định vời bệnh vệnh vĩnh giữ hình mô tạng.
Bởi lòng nhìn ảy, ra định vui bệnh đời nơi đe đo tận nghiêm tiêm, phổi, lăn và tình của anh để kêu xong những người khác đang chờ đổi sự sống.
Đúng mề bốn xử 3 mi phút miệng mung xí tháng 15 năm, hành hình khu chăm 1 mi làm, sau phút mặc nghiệp,
eki phó thật vùng các truy ra đồng mềng cùng đường mũi bác sĩ mình vỉnh đa qua bà dựa đã tính hành phó thật lấy và bảo quan tạng theo đúng quy trình truyên mô.
Công tác phần chuyển được khó chợ đặc biệt mời các cán mũ, chính sĩ đổi kẻ xa xa thông số 2 và đổi kẻ xa xa thông năm xe ngon.
Bảo đam các cuộc quan tạng được chuyển đến khi thời gian đơn vị tiếp nhận hông, mềng vịnh trở giấy,
mềng vịt đại học í dược thành phố chi mình, mềng vịt phụ chụi ui, mềng vịt trụ ui mềng vịt đa qua bà dựa bà dựa bà tỏ rong chiên xấu sắp đến gia đình vui hiến,
những người đã biến lỗi đau mất mát thình món khoả vô ra cho sự sống,
lăng phỏ viên tình nhìn ái và giá chiến văn câu đẹp trong cuộc đồng.